the reason why
you think putin is uh
irreplaceable is be precisely because
he's like you know like a witch from the
snow white you know who's the fairest of
them all well after you poison every
snow white in the country you know
you're the fairest of them all and
that's the logic of putin
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people a brilliant guest we have for you
today all the way from the motherland
itself he is a political activist a
campaign a politician russia's most
prominent libertarian michael svetov
welcome to trigonometry
uh thanks for having me hi constantine
hi
yeah there you go well uh i i
mispronounced your name or i pronounced
it in the english way to start with
after you spent five minutes training
francis to pronounce it correctly uh but
listen welcome to the show before we get
into the conversation tell everybody a
little about who you are how are you
where you are because you're not
actually in russia at the moment what
has been your journey through life that
leads you to be sitting here talking to
us
well i'm russia's most prominent
libertarian as you mentioned uh before
and i've been really active in russian
activist circles for a couple of years
now and uh i've organized some of the
most successful rallies in russia not
many people know that libertarian party
of russia organized a rally of 60 000
people in moscow just couple of years
ago two years ago to be exact uh in
defense of free speech online in defense
of
privacy of conversation in defense of
telegram it was a big news
in the international media as well and i
i played a major role in organizing
those those rallies i'm also famous for
uh reading lectures about libertarianism
and my biggest accomplishment is that i
actually
toured russia from kaliningrad to
yugoslavia because that's the far east
of russia uh reading lectures in over 70
cities of russia all of them were very
successful and that's my biggest
accomplishment something i'm most proud
of apart from lectures and uh
the other thing i'm really proud of is i
organized lecture by hans hermann hope
in moscow it was the most
uh the biggest lecture uh read by a
libertarian in the world uh over 1600
people attended it was it took place in
the big concert hall the recording is
available on my youtube channel and
nothing like this at least as far as i
know has never been done anywhere else i
mean 1600 people listening to a lecture
read by a philosopher and economist
that's something so whenever people act
surprised that russia has a libertarian
party and it's been quite prominent for
for the last several years i always act
surprised in return because you know we
did things that seem impossible even in
the u.s
and seem ridiculous in europe so that's
something i'm really proud of
well it's great to have you on and i
think uh we'll get into some of your
work
a little bit further on but i think it's
impossible to discuss anything about
russia particularly for a western
audience which is mostly who we have
without contextualizing it a little bit
because uh most people i know this for a
fact in the west don't really understand
what's happening to be honest with you i
don't i wouldn't even claim to
necessarily know the ins and outs of
what's going on so can you give people
first of all a broad perspective of
where russia is today what has happened
uh who is vladimir putin how has he been
in power for so long you know all the
electoral shenanigans that are going on
all of that can you just give people a
big picture of you before we get into
everything else well yeah russia is in a
very difficult place right now uh we
just had elections two days ago and they
were a fraud with uh uh with uh
falsifications with a ballot stuffing
and things like that and basically
united russia that's the putin's party
claimed the victory uh even though they
didn't gather enough votes to actually
win properly but there's nothing a civil
society can do so there's no rallies
because most of the activists has been
jailed uh like the last nine months were
spent just jailing every single
dissident in russia so the the biggest
story you probably heard about is the
story of alex navalny who's been
poisoned by novichok in last year
he survived he found people who attacked
them he dared to come back to russia and
he was apprehended and put to jail right
in the airport when he uh when he
when he boarded off the plane so that's
the situation we've been
we've been struggling with in the past
months and i myself had to leave russia
because most of my team like the people
who made the successes that we'll be
talking about today possible uh last
year two years ago three years ago most
of them were dispersed some of them are
under house arrest right now some of my
closest allies are under house arrest
most of my allies had to flee russia i
left russia myself as well not because
of the direct political prosecution even
though just three months ago i was in
jail three months ago i had a another
house search my house searched again so
that's the kind of pressure we are
living under and russia has been very
very difficult place to do any kind of
political activism but and it's getting
worse unfortunately
it's interesting that you're saying it's
getting worse because hasn't russia
always had this history of you know
powerful leaders crushing down on you
know the individuals and you know the
people who live in russia
yeah but we had this window of freedom
um 20 years from our early 90s to let's
see to the late 90s that uh
that felt freer than ever before but now
that putin cracked back uh
cracked back on the civil society now
it's getting really bad again so russia
today is very different from russia two
years ago as i mentioned uh the kind of
work i've been doing in russia for the
past years is impossible today like the
biggest example two years ago i opened
um the first libertarian club in russia
called new sincerity and it felt like a
good idea just two short years ago but
then the whole thing with navalny
happened the poisoning his survival his
return home and his incarceration and
now it's something that's impossible to
imagine i had to close it down police
raided several times they forced us to
close for several months and it's
impossible to hold a place of
conversation anymore even though a kind
of conversation was possible just
recently even less than a year ago it
was still possible really the things
turned uh to the worst nine months ago
when alexey navalny came came back to
russia and why is that why is this
sudden crackdown happening is it because
putin has felt that his power is being
threatened that he's not as strong as he
used to be therefore he needs to
introduce more draconian measures
well he's a as strong as he used to be
uh the reason why he's cracking down is
because he saw example of ukraine he saw
example of bella russia i think that's
uh what triggered him mostly uh he saw
that people flooded the streets and he
wanted to act in advance he wanted to
prevent them from happening talking
about the
i'm talking about the protests in
ukraine i mean ukraine had a proper
revolution below russia had an attempted
revolution which failed uh thanks well
thanks uh to uh to the draconian
measures of lukashenko you probably
heard about it as well so putin wanted
to to act in advance he wanted to uh to
not allow this kind of protest to happen
to shake his power so he cracked down on
any
kind of person who dared to say
something again against the party so um
he's uh he's a smart tactician i think
what people don't realize about putin is
that he's uh he's a very smart
politician he's bad for the russian
people he's bad for the for the country
but he's uh very smart in the way he
deals with power uh and that's why he's
been staying in power for over 20 years
now mikhail let me take you back to my
earlier question because we didn't get a
chance to get into put your historian
hat on for us
let's go back to 1998
when you and i were both quite young
still
yeah explain to people the entire
process since because uh most people in
the west don't know how vladimir putin
came to power they don't know how he
managed to serve more terms than was
originally allowed by the constitution
they don't understand the whole
uh
situation with the dmitry medvedev like
just give us a brief history of the last
20 years because i think that would be
very helpful for any conversation okay
well uh putin has been appointed as a
successor of yeltsin boris yeltsin the
president of russia uh nobody knew who
he was back then they uh
they felt like he they he can be easily
controlled that's why all the oligarchs
russian oligarchs backed him as well but
when he rose to power he uh emerged as
this kind of strong man quite popular at
the time with the with the general
public because he was cracking down on
oligarchs and nobody liked oligarch so
he basically cracked down on the same
people who brought him to power and that
gave him a very great measure of support
in his first eight years when he was in
power then he sort of surround
surrendered
the presidential post to dmitry medvedev
who was his closest ally and
at the time everybody was caught talking
about how dmitry medvedev can
prove to be a liberal shift
in the politics of russia how he was
different from putin's but to me it all
felt it always felt ridiculous because i
remember the interviews that putin gave
in 1999 when he was first appointed as a
prime minister back then before he
became president one of the first
interviews he gave he was asked you know
other people you trust uh
you can trust 100 percent other people
you can rely on and he named one person
whom nobody knew at the time
whose name country didn't learn for
another eight years and that was dmitry
medvedev he said that's the person i can
rely on 100 percent so when they made
the switch rue when medvedev became
became president i was sure that you
know that's basically the same party the
same person ruling the country and it
proved to be correct when they switched
back uh four years after that when
medvedev uh seceded the the presidential
post to back to putin again and after
that after that
things turned more authoritarian so if
in the first eight years putin generally
was a very liked president like i didn't
like him most of dissidents didn't like
him but it was hard to argue that he was
really popular uh after that uh the
ukrainian war happened this the
annexation of crimea uh and that gave
him a different kind of boost the
different kind of boost of popularity
than he had before uh the the the
patriotic the sensibilities rose and he
rode this this way for for several years
again now it's a different story he
doesn't have a success story anymore
he's burned he's burdened by the
mistakes and he's burdened by the
economic stagnation uh but he's um
he's driven by will of power and his
closest allies he's the the circle of
people that's been with him for 20 years
it's so uh
tight and uh so well organized that
there's really nothing you can
you can do to
to
um
to fight against it unfortunately so and
the
the last the last development was the
the whole thing with alexis naval in
belarussia alexey navalny got poisoned
bella russia had attempted revolution
which gave putin this historical sense
that revolution is something he had to
prevent in russia and that's what he's
doing right now and uh yeah and would
you say that he is a good leader not in
terms obviously of human rights where
russia's human rights record is abysmal
but in the way that he runs the country
the way he runs it fiscally
uh you see there's different between
there's a difference between good leader
and competent leader he's a competent
leader i don't think he's a good leader
i think he's driving country to the
ground but uh he's been doing it very
competently and
he didn't allow any kind of any kind of
uh
dissent uh during his uh
five terms in power now
and why is it that he's been allowed to
serve five terms if as uh constantine
alluded to there was a set limit
well there is a limit
on consecutive terms so you can't stay
uh president for three consecutive terms
only two consecutive terms but uh if you
make a switcheroo the kind of switcheroo
that he did with mitri medvedev then
you're allowed an extra two consecutive
terms and then we had this referendum
well it wasn't really a referendum it
was a plebiscite uh where he asked
people
if it was all right for him to change
the constitution to allow him to stay in
power pretty much indefinitely and
that's happened last year the big
plebiscite so now there is no limit
whatsoever
and
the one thing that we think of putin in
in the west is that his ruthlessness
particularly when it comes to his
enemies and particularly when it comes
to the use of poison why does he do that
why and particularly why is it always
poison
because it works i mean uh the question
you should ask yourself is why shouldn't
he do what he does because it leads him
to it allows him to reach the goals that
he sets so at the ends just to justify
the means he deals in real politics so
he doesn't really have an ideological
agenda that's what people in the west
don't really realize i think and he does
whatever works so the poison works so
why not use poison it's less messy than
hiring an assassin it's
less troublesome than dealing with
people politically you know and he's not
as acute uh in public politics as he is
in real politics and real politics works
so whatever works he's willing to do but
hang on surely like you know if you look
at the case of alexander litvinenko
which happened around 15 years ago the
salisbury poisonings i mean that's been
condemned by all everybody around the
world practically surely that isn't an
effective tactic is it does not just
alienate
well of course it is an effective tactic
okay he's been condemned but what did
the west really do to putin i mean there
hasn't been really any meaningful
sanctions there hasn't been any
meaningful backlash when he annexed
crimea you know all the west did he said
well you shouldn't really do that so he
feels like he feels like he's been doing
everything exactly the way it should
have been done
uh and uh i understand this will be a
difficult question for you to answer but
let me ask you anyway
liberal minded people like you and i are
thinking right of russian background or
who lived in russia
i think we're in the minority wouldn't
you say would is not fair to say that
most people in russia
support what vladimir putin is doing i
mean i would argue and i've argued many
times in the past and you know feel free
to argue with me which i think you will
um you know russia has never been a
democracy there's never been a single
democratic transition of power truly
democratic transitional power in the
entire history of our country going back
centuries and centuries and centuries
isn't vladimir putin just one of those
you know peter the great ivan the
terrible you know whatever just the
typical russian leader and russian
people love that
well he he definitely likes to think of
his of himself that way but i think
people never had a chance to actually
develop this kind of tradition so there
is always a moment in time where you
know
democracy emerges out of and free
society and russia had the chance you
know if the leaders allowed that for
that you know this tradition could have
emerged we've seen the same thing
happening in the eastern europe for
example after the period of the soviet
occupation you know they developed
healthy democracies in russia we were
never allowed that so i think it's an
unfair question to ask you asking if
putin is really you know his his uh
means are justified if he's uh really
popular because we don't know really
there is no freedom of speech there is
no freedom of association any kind of
political organization is being crushed
once it reaches any kind of success so
the kind of institution that could have
developed in the past 20 years that
could have became a backbone of a new
free society were crushed so of course
right now there is no alternative to
putin but the only reason there is no
alternative to putin is because putin
did everything in his power uh to make
it so that's his uh that's his uh the
i think it's what all tyrants and all
dictators do really they destroy any
meaningful opposition and they come to
to the public and say well look there is
nobody except me and that's exactly what
putin did
so how popular do you think he actually
is because you make a very good point
for example ceausescu the romanian
dictator he had a 93 approval rating the
day before he was taken out and shot
right so he was obviously not that
popular but but in in dictatorships i
take your point
the popularity rating according to polls
is kind of irrelevant so how popular do
you think he actually is in in russia i
think he was very popular throughout
most of his time in power but i think it
changes right now and the the last
election we had just two days ago uh
showed that his party united russia
couldn't uh
achieve the success that they were
hoping for so they had to use false they
had to use tough ballots they had to use
they had to falsify the elections in
order to to secure the seats that they
that they needed and there's a really
clear evidence that the last election
was heavily falsified uh on both ends on
offline ballots real life ballots and on
the digital uh election front as well we
have this digital election system uh
based on blockchain that that's been
used to uh to actually swing the
election in favor of united russia
mikhail
wouldn't you say that actually
russia needs a putin you know because
it's a country that is not particularly
stable
it's large and if you have a democracy
wouldn't that therefore mean that
there'd be certain parts of it that want
to become independent and it would be
fundamentally unstable as an entity
well i think people should be given a
chance uh
there will never be an alternative to a
dictator as long as there is a dictator
in power so we will never know what
would the uh what other options are so
we have this uh well he's an opposition
leader
we call him that alex navalny the the
man i mentioned earlier and uh he
managed to gather a serious support in
russia he had chapters of his uh of his
organizat organization in every major
city in russia he uh he ran for mayor of
moscow and almost won uh several years
ago and he hasn't been allowed to to
participate in elections ever since so
uh the the the reason why
you think putin is uh
irreplaceable is be precisely because
he's like you know like a witch from the
snow white you know who's the fairest of
them all well after you poison every
snow white in the country you know
you're the fairest of them all and
that's the logic of putin
and has his brain been undermined is
coronavirus playing a big factor in this
that
go for it
yeah well i think uh the whole thing
with coronavirus is just uh
it's been so depressing not just in
russia but in the entire world as well
in russia it's being used exactly the
same way it's been used in the us and in
australia right now and basically every
time it's convenient you know you crack
down you say that there's a quarantine
uh you have to stay home there is this
whole uh criminal case against activists
right now who are basically uh being
framed for spreading the coronavirus by
orga by means of organizing a political
rally so it is being used for political
means whenever it's convenient but
whenever there is a
big prestigious event like uh the
uh like the the the european football
match that took place in in uh in st
petersburg a couple of months ago you
know all these all the quarantine
measures are being lifted whenever there
is an election and that was very very uh
funny as well we had elections that i
mentioned to the two days ago and all
the quarantine measures were lifted and
once they were over um the government
came in and said well you know you can't
have rallies you can't oppose the
election results because we have
coronavirus and actually we're bringing
back your codes as well so it is being
used by a tyrannical government to
to
uh to to reach its political means yeah
i michael the other thing that people in
the west often associate with russia
without really understanding the full
meaning is people describe russia as a
kleptocracy which i know is another
thing one of the things that you would
be concerned about as an opposition
activist can you explain to people in in
in a kind of broad brush detail
what that actually means because i think
again in my experience people in the
west have absolutely no idea what what
we're talking about
well kleptocracy basically is when you
have uh the ruling clause and the putin
and his closest associate dealing with
uh using the government budget as their
own piggy bank and that's what they've
been doing for the past 20 years every
single friend of putin's became
extremely rich in the past 20 years and
the kind of crippled down economy that
they usually took in the west it works
it works in the in the nepotism kind of
way in russia if you know someone who
knows putin you will be well off if you
manage to suck to the government you'll
be well off but there's no really a fair
economy there's no really market economy
anymore because everything relies on if
you have connections uh then you can do
business if you don't have connections
like pavel duro for example he was the
one
he was the only real capitalist we had
he created kentucky uh social network
which is the biggest rival of facebooks
in russia and it occupies a major part
of the market and it's been basically
stolen from him by the putin's oligarch
alicia osmanov
so he had to flee russia and he created
telegram and telegram became the biggest
messaging platform in russia as well but
it's not based in russia anymore because
it's dangerous and paddle durov
basically can't return back to his home
country uh under under threat of arrest
so basically whatever putin's cronies
want they take
and there's no repercussion because
there's no fair trial there's no uh
justice system everything is corrupt and
uh everything is for grabs if you're in
power
amica when i was in
china there was a very sort of similar
system in many ways however for the
average chinese person
if you don't get involved in politics if
you don't question authority if you just
want to go about and live your life
life is actually not bad in fact it's
pretty good is that the same in russia
well uh i actually argue about that uh
in regard to russia and china as well
because you never know what may become
politics tomorrow and there there is
this huge case be uh happening right now
in russia the case of uh
yuri kovansky who was a blogger he
reviewed the food you know junk food and
stuff like that an apolitical whatsoever
but 10 years ago just think about 10
years ago he sang a song about a
terrorist act that happened in moscow it
was a satirical song it was made in bad
taste but it was a satirical song saying
by someone who was never involved in
politics in his life and just couple
couple of months ago he was brought to
trial he's tried as an extremist and a
terrorist he's actually in the same list
as a uh
as a isis terrorist right now he's been
put in the same list by the russian
government uh for singing a song 10
years ago so you never know what may
become politics you never know when you
may become inconvenient and it's uh been
spreading like a rash uh in the past
months because once the uh the thing
with repressive machine is that once you
get rid of real enemies or at least some
people you perceive as real enemies you
still need someone to oppress because
you need to prove your worth to the
government to the people that are paying
your money to the people that uh
decide that you are still useful so you
have to invent enemies and once the real
political activists are out of the
picture
they start to prosecute innocent people
and that's what happened to yuri
kavansky my good friend maria matuzna
she's been in the western news as well
she was in the list of extremists and
terrorists as well for sending a meme in
her private message to a friend when she
was living in uh in a tiny city in
russia so she was not a political
activist back then she is now because of
the story she went through but she was
not a political activist back then and
still she was tried as a terrorist
simply for sending a meme and there are
stories
like this happening all the time the
biggest one
out of three is the case of ruslan
sokolovsky who was a blogger as well and
he was he recorded a video catching
pokemons playing pokemon go inside a
church and for posting that video uh
he's been put in the list of terrorists
and extremists the same kind of list
where people who actually bomb and kill
people uh are being put in and um it
took us over a year to to to help him uh
get out of trouble so no it's not enough
it's not good enough uh if you're not
interested in politics because one
because politics will get interested in
you and uh when it happens there's
nobody left to help you um mikhail you
you mentioned something that i think is
actually very important something that
you know i haven't lived in russia for
over 20 years now but the one thing i
really do associate very strongly with
is russian culture russian
literature russian
the whole cultural sphere which you know
russia has produced some of the greatest
poets the greatest artists the greatest
writers a little bit depressing but
nonetheless the greatest writers in in
history even during very difficult
oppressive times
what has been the impact of the last 20
years on the cultural life of russia on
the ability to produce the great
saturation i know that for example one
of the people i really used to respect
like viktor shanderovich he he's not
able to really be a satirist anymore
he's become a sort of dissident
commentator because he can't actually
make comedy shows on tv as he used to
and other things like that has has all
of this stunted the cultural aspect of
russia has actually spurred it on as it
has done sometimes in the past
uh no no it stunted the russian culture
as well and it ceased to be
international like the kind of authors
you are uh referring to the dostoyevsky
and tolstoys they were they were all in
the past and the soviet here during the
soviet times we have this saying that
the stalin he took russia with great
russian literature and left and left
russia with the
literary societies and it sounds better
in russian anyway it does yeah
but the point is the point is that uh
we don't have a strong culture anymore
because culture needs freedom and
the much better example to be honest is
what happens in the in china
i've always been fascinated that china
managed to become this economic
juggernaut you know they have these
factories and they import pretty much
all the uh consumer goods uh to the
world but there hasn't been a single
decent movie coming out of china in 20
years there hasn't been a single good
song coming out of china in 20 years
sure they produce local culture but
there hasn't been uh
any cultural success international
cultural success coming out of a country
of almost 2 billion people and they
haven't had a gangnam style
yeah well gangnam song is is korean you
know that's that's the point i'm making
you know korea they have k-pop and they
have the um
the the the literal the the movies you
know uh the parasite was a great movie
the korean cinema is on the rise you
know the japan they had the anime and
manga that took world by uh by storm and
that's the country of what 150 million
people and a hundred a country of two
billion people didn't produce a single
decent uh cultural product that tells
you something about the uh how freedom
affects the society so it's the same
thing in russia uh russia doesn't have
its intellectual freedom anymore and
when you have no intellectual freedom
you have no culture unfortunately
that's such a good point about freedom
and mikhail one of the things i wanted
to ask you and i think a lot of our
audience would be curious to know i know
people often are interested in my
opinion about things as an outsider but
you are sort of much fresher off the
boat if you like in terms of leaving
russia much more recently
what do you see
in the west as an outsider in terms of
you know i think a lot of people in
russia would look at the west often as
as a place where there's a lot of
freedom maybe some people would not in
russia would think there's too much
freedom but nonetheless
what do you notice as as a person who's
been forced to to to be in different
parts of the world you've you've been to
all over the place new zealand brazil et
cetera uh what do you see as an outsider
well the the biggest problem the ways
the west faces today is the loss of
moral high ground and i've been writing
about it incessantly is that the u.s
during the cold war the u.s was this
shining beacon of hope you know freedom
an example we were striving to follow
but now it's much harder to make that
case because there is no more uh moral
high ground left and the biggest blow to
to my ideology like libertarian ideology
came from the u.s it came from the
ideals that founding fathers
were talking to the ideas of classical
liberalism the ideas of individual
freedom the ideas of
just law but
when julian assange was first
put under house arrest in the ecuadorian
embassy and now he's under proper arrest
in the uk
to me that seems unthinkable i can't
defend the freedom of speech as
efficiently as i used to be able to
because now every time i bring up you
know the western media there is always
this case of julian assange that's
basically a person who's been
incarcerated for doing editorial work he
was working as a journalist he never had
access to uh secret documents he never
had access to government secrets so why
is he in jail nobody can there is no
good explanation the other big blow was
of course the the what happened to
edward snowden and again there's much
better case that can be made against
edward snowden that he actually uh did
commit a government crime it was for the
good he was a whistleblower but there
was an actual crime taking place but i'm
i was fascinated that the only country
that edward snowden found refuge in was
putin's russia that tells you something
he couldn't go to merkel's germany he
couldn't go to france uh he couldn't go
to netherlands he couldn't even fly
through europe because
because there was a threat that the the
plane will be landed uh somewhere and he
will be extradited to back to the us so
he had to to seek refuge in putin's
russia and that was a huge a huge win
for putin that was a huge win for his
prestige i think and
i think that's something the west should
really reflect on because the loss of
moral high ground has been this red
threat
that's been going through western
politics in the last 10 to 15 years and
it's getting worse day by day and i
understand that this whole justification
of you know a noble lie you know we have
to do that to prevent a catastrophe from
happening but uh
that's what brings about a catastrophe
like what happened during the elections
of to 2020 in the u.s
for it divided the country not it
it was
let me rephrase myself so politics
became global right so whatever happens
whenever something happens in the us
whenever something happens in united
kingdom or in europe uh it's uh being
interpreted by the government and by the
governments and by the civil societies
of other countries and in russia of
russia as well and when we saw what
happened during the 2020 when donald
trump was uh banned from all social
media
just think what kind of message it sent
to vladimir putin hey here's this
platform you know twitter facebook
google whatever youtube that claims to
be a platform of free speech yet they uh
banned the most powerful person in the
world who was
to become the biggest opposition leader
in the us because they can because it's
politically convenient so they're not
protecting freedom of speech anymore
they're using it to to uh to sway
elections they're using it to um
to silence the descent i will do the
same in russia because not just because
they're doing the same but because
then them controlling
who gets to say what on twitter is
direct threat to russian politics within
uh within uh russian society because
everyone in russia uses twitter as well
and just think what it means in terms of
election just think what it means in
terms of google was to ban uh
someone from united russia from its feed
uh it was it can sway election in
elections in russia and that sort of
drives putin's
that sort of drives his distrust to the
west
and it drives distrust of the civil
society as well because we see these
things happening in in the west and now
we doubt if it actually can be better so
the biggest weapon the uh the
the us had during the cold war was its
moral high ground was its uh
respect for
uh respect for values even if when it
was inconvenient but now that it lost
that
it's really hard to distinguish between
putin and biden for example because yeah
there are nuances and there's no moral
equivalency yet but
it's looking much grayer
and the distinction is uh much less
pronounced than it used to be just 10
years ago
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
isn't it also as well mikhail is that at
one point you saw america as a unified
country whereas you look at america now
it seems to be a country a war with
itself
oh yeah but but it's uh it's america's
problem so america always had dissent
within its borders and i think it's
quite normal for a democracy for a
liberal democracy to disagree with each
other uh but what i think is not normal
is uh having the kind of
putinesque
censorship that's taking place in social
media and i know there is this uh this
uh
fig leaf of explanation that you know
well it's a private property so they can
ban whomever they want but we
saw the leaks from the white house that
you know the white house actually helps
facebook and helps twitter to create
white lists of people who it will not
ban uh we saw the conversation that the
tech oligarchs had with the democratic
administration just before the election
so it all raises red flags and uh i
think this is a much bigger story
i agree with you but to summarize what
you said and i think
i i really want to people to get the
point that you're making which is when
we in the west fail to live up to our
stated goals and ideals we not only are
we undermining our own society we are
giving power to dictators and tyrants
around the world because they can point
at the west and go well look they're not
doing freedom why wouldn't i just
i want just to precise your point a
little bit it's not just about pointing
uh in the in the other direction and
saying why can't we do the same it's
also about real politics and i mentioned
real politics before is uh
people in other countries use western
social media and when western social
media is uh being censored in favor of a
political party or a political force in
the u.s
it triggers every single other country
to uh you know to to to defend itself
because it feels like the same kind of
private censorship call it what you will
will be used in local elections as well
to sway the elections in favor of a
different country of a country that
controls facebook or twitter
or youtube or google or whatever so in
terms of real politics it's a much
graver situation so it's not just
ideology it's not just moral high ground
uh it's uh
it's real politics that that changes at
all so the the reason why putin is so uh
became so aggressive in censoring
western uh social medias in russia is
because he feels that the western social
media can be used to interfere in
russian elections the same thing is
being felt in hungary the same thing is
being felt in poland and to be fair this
the same thing is being felt in france
as well because uh well you remember the
reaction of uh macron and angela merkel
in germany when donald trump was banned
they didn't endorse it one bit because
they felt that the same kind of
instrument can be used to sway elections
in their own uh constituencies
well they're not they're they're smart
then because this is the point i've been
trying to make to to bridge politicians
as much as i can you gotta understand
these people are gonna have the power to
decide whether you get reelected or not
if you allow this to continue and not
enough people i think i think grasp that
so with that in mind what about the the
sort of the stuff that you and i talked
about when i was on your show the
culture
war if you like the cultural
debates the cultural i mean it's not
debates really it's war at this point i
think that the the
we're seeing here in the west all of the
discussions about sort of reshaping
society is that happening in russia uh
or or is is that
is that a thing that sort of westerners
rich and bored as we are can get
involved with no it is it is uh uh it is
being discussed in russia as well
primarily because everyone in russia
uses western social media and that's
being interpreted by putin as a kind of
a cultural war
especially after uh everything that we
just discussed after the censorship
started to take place etc etc so it is a
factor it's not a major factor because
the the grasp of traditional media in on
russian audience is still quite
strong stronger than it is in the west i
think but it is being discussed and i
think one other factor that is rarely
discussed and i'm going to put it in the
most
most
mild words possible is that well the the
reality of politics in the world is that
uh um whenever you have an opposition
the opposition seeks whatever support it
can get and it seeks up support in other
countries as well and the us is the
country that is most generous with its
support and its support is conditional
so whenever it starts to help a certain
political group uh within russia and i'm
not naming names and i'm not going to
tell who i'm referring to but it's uh
it's um happening happens all the time
they uh condition their support with a
certain cultural agenda and democratic
party is much more willing to to give
money for this sort of for this sort of
activism so what you get is that you the
the
the political opposition within borders
within borders of a country russian
borders for example
gets colored with a certain cultural
agenda and that in my opinion that uh
really uh
whomever accept this kind of support
shoots themselves in the leg
i'm very sorry i'm just very sorry i
know i know what exactly you mean but
let me state as russianly and bluntly as
i can okay you're talking about i
imagine and correct me if i'm wrong the
u.s says here's some money for your
position
efforts
but you've got to you've got to focus it
on
lgbtq plus
blah blah blah which will automatically
discredit you massively in the eyes of
ordinary russian people
absolutely that's exactly what is
happening and i think the most obvious
example of that we saw in afghanistan
you saw the videos uh flowing from
afghanistan they had gender studies
being taught in kabul they had you know
people talking about feminism and i mean
okay those those are values that i
understand you feel like you have to
defend those values but you also have to
take into consideration you know the
kind of culture that country has you
know and work within that culture
because otherwise uh you'll just uh
you'll never achieve the kind of hands
of
building a functional society that were
put
that you were striving for in in
afghanistan that's i th and that's what
i think brought uh brought the war to
the fiasco that it had uh in russia the
same thing happens as well the reason i
didn't want to put it as bluntly as you
did is because i have a lot of friends
you know who will be watching this show
and they'll take it personally and i
didn't want them to take it personally
but that's well now they will
[Laughter]
no look i i'm not making any any
judgments about it i'm just trying to
tease out the point that you're making i
think uh yeah and that makes sense to me
as someone who understands russian
culture from the inside uh i don't think
uh it's it would be accurate to say that
russia has progressed quite as far as we
have in the west in terms of
accepting people for who they are
and therefore to make an additional
extraordinary emphasis on these marginal
issues of sexual identity or whatever
would be very off-putting to the
ordinary russian person and therefore
would quite likely undermine the
effectiveness of an opposition
yeah yeah well uh that happens as well
it also shifts the power balance within
the opposition because basically
whomever has support from the u.s or
from the uk or from europe you know they
have money they have support of western
media and the kind of people who get the
support of western media are not
necessarily the kind of people who will
be successful within domestic politics
and it brings all kinds of chaos uh into
domestic politics straight away
mikhail look this is a question that a
lot of people are going to want answered
because we've had an in very insightful
very interesting conversation but you're
talking to us from georgia why are you
in georgia at the moment
well i'm in georgia in the moment
because during the elections there was
this serious crackdown on all kinds of
opposition and i mentioned that just
three months ago i've been in jail i
spent 10 days in jail it was my fourth
time that i was arrested i had my house
searched
i had my friends threatened and a lot of
my allies had to leave as well i'm in
georgia right now because
i came here just for two weeks i spent
the last three months in south america
in brazil i came to georgia to see some
of my friends who are not as well off as
i am who are living here right now and
who have no way to come back because
once they return they'll be arrested the
same way that alexis navalny was
arrested the same way
andre pivovarov a good friend of mine he
was actually took off the plane out of
russia so he was
about to leave russia he he went through
all the controls the passport control
etc but they took him off the board of
the plane and put him in jail just for
for being a political activist so it's
dangerous to do politics in russia today
do you think you're going to be able to
go back
i definitely hope so i am not i don't
consider myself a political immigrant
because i don't like the kind of stigma
that
uh that it has but um
my hope is that i will be able to return
i'm just not sure when
and
in the u the in the west we tend to
paint russia almost as the enemy do you
think russia
is a serious threat to the west or do
you think not really that exact that is
no that is an exaggeration by the
western media trying to create a
bogeyman etc etc uh i think russia is
the most convenient boogeyman possible
because uh it's uh incapable of really
posing any kind of serious threat just
look at the gdp that russia has look at
the state of economy look at uh at its
uh well it has a decent defense budget
but still it's a it's a local empire
it's not a global empire like it used to
be during the soviet era so if you were
but it's much more convenient to
to to prop up russia as this big enemy
because china is scary
and uh you know
ruining relations with china nobody can
afford to ruin relations with china but
pretty much everyone can afford to ruin
relations with russia and that gives you
an idea that russia is not really uh
does not really pose a serious threat
because when someone does pose a serious
serious threat you don't
you don't uh
deal with it the same way that russia
has been dealt with by the west
well the last time the soviet union
posed a genuinely serious threat
that we had to re what the west had to
react to was the cuban missile crisis
when you know the west america pulled
out all the stops to prevent russia from
having its nuclear missiles right on its
border and i guess what you're saying is
the passive response to the poisonings
of people in in western countries the
invasion of ukraine etc etc shows you
that the west isn't really that bothered
about what russia is doing because it's
kind of local affairs they killed off a
few russian guys in london whatever who
gives a [ __ ] really yeah yeah exactly
that russia so russia does its thing and
it can like poison a politician in
london if it really wants to but it will
be a russian politician it doesn't have
a real sway in the european election and
the whole russia gate that happened in
the us just felt so ridiculous come like
watching from russia you know nobody
could have done a better pr campaign for
putin than the democratic party did
because they basically created this kind
of you know demigod you know who rules
the american elections who rules the
european elections you know who has his
hand pretty much in every single crisis
in the world and that's i mean yeah i'm
putin is being fl has been flattered by
this kind of coverage and it's uh it did
a lot to raise his prestige within
russia because uh if you remember in the
90s uh there it was a decade of
humiliation a lot of russian russians
felt that you know russia's been
humiliated by the by the term of boris
yeltsin and when putin came back he said
well you know from now on russia will be
respected and the kind of you know
russian russiagate stories and the kind
and the propping up putin as a boogeyman
as the world uh white boogeyman is
actually it feels like uh respect when
you uh when you live in russia it feels
like well now you know they're afraid
and if they're afraid you know they
respect us so
i think it did more harm than good in
terms of creating a functional political
system in russia because a lot of people
every time there is another russia gate
happening in the us a lot of people see
it as a sign of strength of putin's
regime
it's very interesting that you say that
because you know we we've been fed this
lie again and again you know the the
reason trump came to power was because
of the russians the reason brexit
happened was because of the russians i
mean you tried to get jeremy corbyn out
there just don't don't you [ __ ] start
don't start with that [ __ ] we did not
try to get jeremy corbyn elected even we
are not that stupid
but
if the russians on uh aren't the real
threat to western democracy you
intimated that it's actually uh the ch
china is that fair or have i put words
in your mouth okay uh well i just
look at the scale of the country i'm not
saying that china is the enemy what i'm
saying is that if you need if you're
looking for an enemy china is a much
better candidate
for this role because of its the scale
of its economy because of the its
population because of its ambitions look
at what happened to hong kong and uh by
the way if we're talking about the
prestige
of the west you know the it's
humiliating to see the
secretary of state anthony blinken you
know deleting the tweet uh that uh the
us will stand uh with ho with the people
of hong kong
it's not it hasn't been forced why would
you delete it at least have guts to
stand by the words even if you're not
gonna do something
so
if you're looking for an enemy china is
a much better candidate because it has
means to to to do harm russia has no
means so why would you even pay
attention to it
amigo we're coming to the end of our
time i know we've got our final question
as usual but i actually feel like is
there something about russia we should
have discussed that we haven't so far
today
i wish we discussed more the the kind of
global politics that we mentioned just
once because politics has become global
a lot of russians speak english a lot of
russians consume western media and
whenever you have this blunders like the
russian gate whenever you have this
whenever you have censorship like what
happened with trump or milo yiannopoulos
you know there are youtube channels that
have uh translated lectures by milo
yiannopoulos that have millions of views
and whenever he's being banned from from
from the social net from the social
media
res it resonates far beyond the
anglosphere it resonates far beyond the
us we see that and we see how it's
similar to what's happening within our
own countries and we mentioned alexey
navalny for example there was this huge
discussion when alex jones was banned
from twitter and youtube etc that you
know well alex jones is being banned but
alex and navalny is still allowed a
platform on the same media when the same
case can be made against alex and
navalny for having his own channel
removed from youtube for example and
alex and navalny realized that himself
when donald trump has been banned on
twitter he he wrote an article basically
saying that's an unacceptable act of
censorship because he understood that
the same logic can be applied to any
kind of dissident to any kind of
opposition
leader
in other countries as well so
global politics is the reality and you
have to
think twice when you do something
locally because it especially in the
anglosphere because everyone speaks
english nowadays it's going to resonate
far
beyond what you think is possible the
same goes the same applies for brexit
you feel like brexit is this a local
story that doesn't affect anyone except
the brits but the truth is
when we were looking at the referendum
and the attempts to rerun the referendum
the whole world's been following that
the whole world's been following the
trump trump re-election the whole world
read about hunter biden's laptop and the
whole world saw that the same articles
that got you banned on twitter just a
year ago
are being reprinted by politico today
for example by saying hey you know
there's been some truth to that let's
let's look into it now that the
elections are gone it's safe to discuss
it the same has happened with the
coronavirus but we're not going to get
into that so the the biggest point i'd
like to make is that politics is global
especially in the anglo-sphere uh
whatever happens in your district you
know we're discussing in russia we're
discussing politics of florida today of
california because the cultural victory
that the united states and united
kingdom achieved in the past 100 years
has also made you
a target
have made the your domestic politics a
target of international uh of
international attention and that's the
that should
leave a imprint on how you deal with it
i think but um what do you think is
going to be the future for russia moving
forward
i think it's grim i don't see any kind
of uh solution to the kind of situation
that putin created today uh i think the
only choices are either through a proper
junta or through a revolution
i don't see any other ways forward i may
be wrong but that's how it seems right
now
well on that uh happy note uh mikhail
thank you so much for coming on the show
it's been a real pleasure and i think a
very valuable perspective actually not
only on russia but also on the west and
uh how we ought to be thinking about
some of the decisions that we make and
some of the conversations that we have
so i know that our audience will have
really appreciated we both certainly do
and with that in mind before we ask you
a couple of very special questions from
our fans on locals our last question is
always the same what is the one thing
we're not talking about that we really
should be
i think i already answered that is that
politics is global today especially uh
politics in the anglosphere we should
talk about it more
and we should talk about the
uh the loss of moral high ground by the
west it's uh it makes the world a worse
place whatever
whatever issues you think you're solving
by losing the moral high ground
you're not solving it you're making it
much much worse without the west as an
example it's much harder for people like
myself to fight for freedom in countries
like russia and i'm sure as hell that
it's the same in china it's the same in
india it's the same in uh in africa etc
etc so we need an example and the lack
of example will bring uh the whole world
to a much darker place than it is now
mikael thank you so much for coming on
the show if people want to find you
online what is the best way to do that
well i have a twitter it's i'm svetoff
but it's in russian and i have a youtube
channel that actually has some english
language videos i had a conversation
with hans hermann hope a very prominent
libertarian i had a conversation with
um
with the
director of uh fee
lawrence reed and other prominent
libertarians so you can watch that it
just has russian subtitles but it's in
english
mikhail thank you so much for coming on
and thank you all for watching and
listening at home we really appreciate
you spending this time with us we will
see you very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one or raw show all
of them go out at 7 pm uk time which is
2 p.m eastern and if you want to listen
to trigonometry on the go you can always
download it as a podcast thank you very
much guys and see you soon
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below